これ以上に停車はこれから小さいですね
こんにちはー肇社長とポッカーン editor
ヒップラインだったらはい何で突然来つらいさんの動画とるのってことなんですけども
去年チャンネル登録者数1抜かれたよっていう動画を出してまぁ色々キッズラインさん
と会ってお話する機会があってこう話しているうちに何かどうかそれたらいいなって
いうことになって
動画を一緒にすることになりましたキッズラインが本当にいい子たちなんで普通に
仲良く動画撮ってるだけですはい
[音楽]
ん
[ __ ]ばっかですっごい本会にすると思う
それでキッチュ代の2人が取りに来てるんだけどもおちちゃんなんと
左にプレゼントを準備しましたあああああ
まあを育つということで落とし今って感じなんですけど結構君は何年生
いやねー昇給年生でみちゃんは
待ってるもその年にあったステビアプレゼント
お姉ちゃん準備しましたもう成績の子供にあげる気持ちで追ってきまーなってまず
2個ずつ2つずつ準備しましたこれあげますつけ別の a 1でラック等に散りそう
ねぇ
これがみっちゃんのでこれは航空ので運転しちゃっただけちゃってよ
持ってる持っており毛見つめれば3ターン r 完璧な感じで見てください
おおおおおお
ねすごい人気みたいもう一人様1点限りしてくれちゃったけど保全参観だって肉買って
きちゃったよやたんだよああ
し何が入ってるもっとないとオトナイト
国名分
ねみんな1分だいたいミンメイ
まず違っ
アリですか
アニメございするの好きはやってればいっしょ
うん
をさあできました
もうわーってなってるねー
わあああああああああ
あああああレーダーなんか書いてるんだもーん
[音楽]
e 7まず1個目ですこれぜひ開けます1本 san
yeah
はっはっは国家の2人とも別々のものですまず交換に
を育つといったら腹部からですドンラッキーバー
すっげー
世界でどうなもうさすがに酸素以上になったさほどっぽいを持つは嫌じゃないん
受けて業者だはぁ
8俺もなになってる感じでも知らないんですよでみたいように女の子版も買ったことし
たんだけど売り切れてた
すごい振って何が入るんでしょえっ
めっちゃ競ってない
入った
動い壁材なばるかんだよ
僕は仮面ライダー見せる日程はい次子が福袋ね知らない事が出てきたのしてもらうから
ね
名前よねーっ
なにこれ
こんなんの h スター
[音楽]
ハワイ本当に入っ
可愛いと思ってる woody になっていかない
なおしてみして何それ
[音楽]
いたからねぇ
b カスにどんなに5号から来新聞はないかもしれないからねおっ
何から半分
た万が一に乗ってこれ航空盗んだよねと言っており好き
お願いしますいやあああちょっとずつ良い子ウーフ入ってねーだね入っ
ああああああ
同じだねーことこれ
ニコは焼いよそうよねこれ
どんどん小杉ははいこれはれ
色違いかうーん
ざけんなーそう声ちいこぷらもう撮影ここからをさぶらないよ多分
などのお
これこれは文とラマンっぽい音ネタラミーくるか
ちょっとご覧挙げてみる変形するおもちゃみたいなもの
oo スター延べ床してください
いい
まあ
頭が出ただけじゃねーか玉が出ただけでござい
猫猫脱ぎ男風のプロ
もうテレ爆丸だ爆丸バトルエントリーセットモールなんだけど投げたりする高変形する
ことがあります
rar
もうちょっとから遊ばれた
p
それで頑張ってさ形にしていってくれるの意味とこれを作ってみようか
羽ってくらいほっ
かよあいうのできたう
国道だけ的
何も送らなきゃできないんだそうだよね木今から今後もっとギアス楽しいよくとあれ
お礼を引っ張った10分姉になった冷酷なもんだぐがのこないよごめんなさいに
お菓子んがっちなつインドとトリガーをあげてるんか
こう宛てが
これぞとか
あれこれあこいつといっ
ちょっとちょっと大変かんすっごいたくサーブねー
連絡生あーもうそれで悶絶下国家に応じてくる少
じゃ補足などですよ楽しいのがあるないん
a さあ瑞穂
[音楽]
おおーー抹茶ぴ勝つのね
ぴかちの飛行ばいいんですよ
大一漕ぎだねこれさっき寧1本当に良かった
どうぞ債務がおります
一応一字ああああ
飲料 new
goo
ええええええええええええ
姉ちゃんを入れように作ってくれるそうですよね
えええっ
[音楽]
[拍手]
うおーー
ですすごい勝手に動いてるあを入れるぞ
2杯3杯とこれでキャッホッパー
黒風だねぇうーんよくなかった
ああ
黒白入ってた方です
北への遅月の便でしたーー
でおねえちゃんジェミちゃんにも兼ね前とかあります
おねーちゃんはもう中学生だかなぁ
を持つ馬だっても上はまずどんなおもちゃな
いいと思うんですもっと mimi さんもお子ちゃうっ腰頃じゃないかもしれなくて
わからなかったか
[音楽]
itunes か運営は
goo
であったりとかするはいいいなぁ欲しい
僕の補正の
そんなこともあろう方 o 君にも毎日頭がぁああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
elr